now to what could be a big shift ahead
for netflix users the streaming giant
announced just yesterday it lost nearly
a million subscribers in the last
quarter now that is the second dip in a
row but wall street actually thinks this
was good news what vlad duties here to
explain it all explain is a word vlad
because most companies can't lose a
million subscribers and be told hey
that's good news yeah so let me explain
what's going on here the company
actually told shareholders it is still
losing subscribers just not as many as
it had predicted in an effort to add
more viewers though the company is now
making some major changes to its
platform
streaming giant netflix will release its
reported 200 million dollar action film
the gray man on its platform this friday
with hopes that it can lure back
customers nice try pumpkin it's the
company's attempt at investing in more
franchise-based content as it struggles
with increased competition netflix
shares were sky-high at the start of the
pandemic when everyone was stuck at home
binging content like tiger king had to
kill me to shut me up but in april of
this year its stock tanked after the
company reported losing 200 000
subscribers in its first quarter and
expected to lose 2 million more in the
second i am never going to financially
recover from this but after announcing
yesterday it only lost roughly 1 million
subscribers last quarter and even
forecasted adding 1 million subscribers
this quarter betting on content like
stranger things netflix stock jumped 8
[Applause]
with the effects of inflation though
will that be enough to keep the
streaming giant from turning upside down
when everything else costs more you're
gonna start to look at your streaming
services and netflix is among the most
expensive of those services a household
with these five premium streaming
options pays roughly eighty dollars a
month which is why many choose to
unsubscribe from at least some
i love all of you in recent months
netflix has had to change course and cut
costs from laying off hundreds of staff
to cracking down on password sharing in
some regions by charging additional fees
i gotta warn you again in your band for
life netflix is also launching a cheaper
subscription tier with advertising
they're doing the right things in
pivoting they said they wouldn't have
ads now they are they said they didn't
care about password sharing now they do
so they're going to pivot to try to
capture those subscribers i don't think
it's panic time just yet
the streamer is also chasing new revenue
and new audiences in the video game
market netflix hired multiple executives
in its gaming department in the past
year and has already released mobile
games like stranger things 1984. i did
not know that yeah very cool the the one
thing that's interesting is the gray man
which is their most expensive movie to
date it started billy bob thornton uh
ryan gosling chris evans um it's really
good and there is a franchise potential
there but they're going to need a lot
more gray man's a lot more stranger
things right if they're going to climb
out of this hole one of the things
they're looking at guys is password
sharing i don't blame them there's a
hundred million households in america
that are enjoying netflix but not paying
for it no i know i plead guilty on
occasion i think we've all on occasion
either either you or you don't no no i i
no i have a netflix account i haven't
but i've given my password i'm sorry all
right this is just the evolution of
stealing cable back in the day you
remember people and it's wrong it is
wrong so i don't blame them for trying
right but at what point is that wrong
because the definition of family can be
pretty flexible oh okay cody
it is 100 100 million homes that are
enjoying this content but that's a lot
they're not making any money but don't
count netflix out i'm not counting
i'm never giving up my netflix account
okay all right vlad thank you very much